لطالما كانت صناعة السيوف [موسيقى] جهدًا مقصورًا على فئة معينة
من الناس ، ولم يكن هناك عدد كبير من الأشخاص الذين يقومون بذلك ، فلديك هذا
التحول من المواد الخام إلى
تغيير الطبيعة وفي النهاية
تحصل على شيء ينضح بالقوة
[الموسيقى]
هذا هو الصلب الفاليري  باع
الأب السيوف القديمة في لعبة Game of Thrones
المصنوعة من الفولاذ الفاليري وكانت أقوى
وأخف من أي سلاح آخر لا أحد
يعرف كيف تم صنعها في العالم الحقيقي
منذ أكثر من ألف عام في
أراضي الفايكنج ، كما كانت هناك أيضًا سلسلة من
السيوف الخاصة ذات الغموض
حاول الحداد في ولاية ويسكونسن أن
يصنع واحدًا من هذا السيف القديم من
حوالي 850 إلى أوائل القرن الـ12 في
الأراضي التي تسيطر عليها الفايكنج ، وكان لديك سيف
يحمل اسمًا يُدعى wolf bert والذي
يُترجم تقريبًا إلى سن الذئب أو
دب الذئب إنه  كلمة القوة لا يوجد سوى
350 سيفًا معروفًا مزورًا
بجودة الفولاذ ولم يظهر
في أوروبا منذ ألف عام أخرى ، ولا
أحد يعرف بالضبط كيف  لقد صنعت
أعتقد أنني اقتربت كثيرًا أو على الأقل
عرضًا جيدًا لكيفية صنع
تلك الشفرات الفولاذية هو مادة خاصة جدًا
نعرف الكثير عنها
ولا نعرف شيئًا عنها تقريبًا لذا
مع بيرت القديم أنت  لديك
فولاذ أسطوري معكوس في لعبة العروش
حيث لديك هذه الصفقة التي لا
يستطيع أحد أن يعيد إنتاجها أن
تقنية صنع السيف الفاليريان الأسود لا تزال
تحمل القليل من الكيمياء
والصوفية فيها نريد أن نصدق أن
هناك شيئًا يمكننا
لا أفهم أنه لا يزال هناك ألغاز في
الصلب
أنت